be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
what's going on guys my name is kitty
and in this video I want to explain cats
it's actually not true kind of a funny
story myself and Mariah actually she was
finishing up her live stream right she's
got this twitch channel called eat codes
and I'll put the link on the on the
screen so you guys can go check it out
as well as in the description but
basically she cooks her way through
video games a video game cookbooks right
like right now she's cooking her way
through the Fallout cookbook which is
really awesome um but when she was
finishing up last night I looked over by
the door and like this kitten ran by and
I was like - there's a kid in outside
she's like we went running over there
and it was trying to crawl under the
house and so we we grabbed it and we fed
it and we gave it some milk and some
water and we're gonna take it to the
Humane Society today to see if it's
microchips and if it is we're going to
return it to the owner and if it's not
then we have a new member of the comics
explained family kitties explained where
does actually a really really cool idea
but uh but we don't have a name for yet
because we're not sure you know if we're
gonna keep her an out but once we keep
her here's a here's a question what name
should we name our cat like what should
we name our cat if we end up being able
to keep her that's what should we name
her that'd be pretty cool anyway guys um
so I'm going to talk about Marvel
confirming their most powerful mutant
ever right because this is kind of a new
revelation that came out recently right
this idea that there is a most powerful
mutant to ever exist it is officially
confirmed by Marvel here's the thing to
bear in mind Marvel up to this point has
not really confirmed the most powerful
mutant in existence right like they said
things like the most powerful mutants
seem will ever to be detected by cerebro
but that's a far shot from the most
powerful mutant in existence right
because basically saying that like it's
the most powerful signal it ever
detected you can kind of extrapolate
that and say well it more or less means
the same thing but not directly right
it's it's like that in between Omega
level and non Omega level in Marvel
Comics you can kind of assume that cage
right you could look at Magneto and say
okay if storm is a mega level because
she can manipulate all the world's
elements right like the weather for now
I'm sorry
not even storm if you can say that that
Iceman is on mega level because you can
basically stop the core movement of the
earth right he can affect the planets
fundamental forces and then in turn
basically freeze the whole place over
then you can in turn look at storm
before she was confirmed and say storms
Oh mega level because she can send the
entire planet into an extinction level
event by losing her mind and
manipulating the weather and then you
look at Magneto and say he's a planetary
threat as well right so if Marvel
routinely used the abilities of a mutant
and on a planetary level to determine
whether or not they were on mega level
then you can basically say any mutant
with that power is considered to be a
mega level right so you can kind of make
that extrapolation but the nature behind
Marvel Comics is that an order for a
mutant to actually be Omega level they
have to be confirmed right like Marvel
has to basically state in the comic an
Omega level threat essentially or an
omega-level mutant something with Omega
level in the name referencing that
particular mutant and the powers they
possess right more recently it's been
Jonathan Hickman in house and powers of
X before that it was just kind of
sporadic in any one particular comic and
that was that um with Marvel confirming
the most powerful mutant in existence
this is a pretty big deal because what
it does is really seem to kind of ignore
a lot of the history that we've seen
with various movies out there which
makes sense because Hickman is doing the
same thing so in in history of the
Marvel Universe
issue number three Marvel confirmed it
to be Franklin Richards now flux you
guys don't know about this history the
Marvel Universe is basically this sort
of miniseries that mark weeds writing
which takes the entire history of the of
the mobile universe and condenses it
down but it's told from the perspective
of Franklin Richards and and Galactus at
the end of all things right which is why
we're gonna cover it because it seems
like an awesome idea but as the universe
is getting ready to end it's just kind
of a conversation between the two right
so the idea about this this is what's so
funny about this is you could literally
read Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
to its completion and then read that and
then just be like okay cool like this is
interesting if it's imperfect really
with with what's going on but it's
basically a history or everything all
the major events right not really the
new wants stuff not the super small
things but the major events that have
happened over the course of Marvel but
Marvel confirming Franklin Richards to
be their most powerful mutant in
existence really begins to bring into
question characters like the Mark II of
Death it brings him to question
characters like Matthew Malloy now
looking at if what hitman is doing in
the x-men combined with what Mark Wade's
doing in history of the Marvel Universe
really seems to point to the idea that
those characters do not and have never
existed right or if they do then they
don't count whether they're just not
being considered as part of the the
events now what also seems to be going
on with regards to what Hickman is doing
is he really seems to be referencing
mutants who were alive well I'd like the
most powerful or I guess I guess really
like
omega-level mutant as they stand now
because I have a hard time believing
that if a character like Jim Jasper's
from Earth 238 was less powerful than
the main Marvel Universe counterpart and
they had to wipe out the alternate
reality version of him in order to
basically save that universe um that you
can't really ignore a power on that
level if we're talking about someone
like Clyde winch him the marquee of
death who had the power to just wipe out
universes with a wave of his hand you
can't really ignore that because that
falls in continuity right that story
took place in the continuity of the
x-men it's not an alternate reality
story it's not like everything happened
and then what's undone it takes place in
that you know in the main Marvel
Universe it historically happened um you
look at characters like like like
Matthew Malloy
right I mean bindus kind of did an
end-run right where Matthew Miller was
super powerful he couldn't control his
powers and those who when they had to go
back and prevent him from being born but
like that event happened right that
story took place and so if all these
things happened in the main Marvel
Universe then it means those mutants had
to have existed and if they existed then
why aren't they being referenced and so
it's interesting because when you look
at history of the Marvel Universe and
then you look at what Hickman's doing
they kind of seem to oppose each other
but confirm each other at the same time
right like Hickman is focusing on x-men
as they exist right now in this moment
in the the current time period as he's
writing the story and saying in this
moment right now these are the most
powerful mutants in existence if Matthew
Malloy existed I imagine he probably
talked him up there if Jim Jasper's
existed I imagine he would talk him up
that right he would say like that
character is there Jim Jasper's is an
interesting case because you had the
version from the main Marvel Universe
who is ultimately defeated by his own
creation in the old Captain Britain
stories but then if you actually go back
and you read the trial of magneto Jim
Jasper's appears there like to sir Jim
Jasper's is actually the one putting is
one of the people putting it on trial
and he looks exactly the same it's not
just name only he looks exactly the same
but there's no reference to the powers
he possesses you know when you when you
look at that kind of concept it's it's
intriguing because it's like these are
super powerful beings who in a lot of
ways seemed to dwarf the power of
Franklin Richards now all that's based
on what we've seen Franklin do right you
look at Franklin's history in the old
Fantastic Four stories what is it like
114 or 117 or it's one of those stories
he aged himself up right like he was
viewers playing with his toys and there
was this commercial that came on that
why don't you grow up and subconsciously
he just like ages himself up into an
adult and looks like Jesus right but he
did it not realizing what it wasn't he
was dealing ultimately you know they
basically you know helped Franklin to
realize where he was but that was when
he became avatar for a short amount of
time but literally the kids aged himself
up using his reality-warping powers uh
there's been points where he's
resurrected Galactus there's been points
where he's defeated Abraxas I mean
there's there's an insane amount of
power that comes out of Franklin but the
issue is that it's so inconsistent and
and and when you look at that I guess
those small little moments here and
there really seem to kind of elevate him
you know up to up to a higher level but
to the to essentially wipe away all
those means that we've talked about
before to basically say that you know
Matthew Malloy is no longer Marvel's
most powerful mutant and instead to say
is Franklin Richards well it is cool and
it does sort of even the playing field
I do kind of miss a lot of that legacy
that was there you know I'm not really
disappointed so much is just kind of
wondering how do those other guys fit in
now the way that Marvel explains this in
terms of Franklin being the most
powerful is they essentially say that
that Galactus and Franklin are kind of a
yin and yang
if Galactus consumes things and destroys
things then then Franklin builds things
now what Mark Waid really seems to be
doing here is building this off the
heels of Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers and Secret Wars have those
you guys don't know what that means for
the most part Avengers and New Avengers
didn't really have anything to do with
Franklin Richards right and Secret Wars
while Franklin did appear there didn't
really do anything until the very very
end right for the most part those those
two stories were about the collapse and
rebirth of the multiverse the difference
is that at the end of Secret Wars what
Marvel or at least what John's and
Hickman sat down is he or what he did is
he sat down and he said okay so
basically like Reed Richards using his
advanced knowledge you know being super
smart used the the abilities of the
molecule man Owen Reese along with
Franklin Richards to create entire
universes and recreate the multiverse
and throw them back in there right so
Franklin was building everything based
on the knowledge that that Reed Richards
has researchers had as well as using the
power of the molecule man Owen Reese to
kind of use all three of those
characters and make it work and put it
out there um it was a cool concept but
because of that because of that level of
power that was displayed by Franklin
that was about the most powerful we'd
ever seen him write powerful enough to
create entire universe
and a lot of that had really come out of
hitman's fantastic fordwick right there
was one point where Franklin his future
self shut up to his younger self in the
present day and said hey looked like I'm
basically turning your powers back on
and there's this really cool moment
where Franklin is under the bedsheets in
his room and he's like creating a
universe in the in the palm of his hand
but I mean and he'd done that before
during heroes reborn he created a whole
universe uh hero's return that universe
was destroyed and Franklin brought them
all back into the main Marvel Universe
we've seen small moments here and there
where he's done that kind of stuff but
having full control over it is something
that we only ever really saw reserved
for his future counterpart and so it's
cool to see what kind of confirm that's
right and say this is absolutely solid
because Franklin basically builds things
while Galactus destroys things so
they're opposites to each other right
and so it works in terms of how this how
this character functions but what it
also confirms and this is one of the
things that I think a lot of people are
sort of missing here and what it also
confirms is that that Franklin Richards
while he isn't really a multiversal
level character and a lot of ways he is
because where he's able to basically
fill in the multiverse by creating whole
universes that really puts him on par in
a lot of ways with the one above all in
terms of the role he plays not in terms
of the power he has but in terms of the
role he plays right the one above all
could just like that and the whole
multiverse is going everything's just
gone and that's it
Franklin doesn't have that kind of power
right I mean nobody really has that kind
of power the marquee of death I guess
you know and do beyonders depending on
you know on who's writing this story
Frank or if it's Jonathan Hickman
probably you know but without them
without him writing it probably not um
the molecule man Owen Reese during the
events of secret Wars - probably but
again that's it's far and few between
you know Protege definitely if he was
exposed to the powers and the one of
them all but nonetheless you know it's
it's it's moving Franklin Richards up to
a supremely high level and saying this
key this guy is basically astronomically
powerful right he's one of most powerful
beings in existence and one of most
powerful beings who ever existed in the
history of Marvel that's a big thing to
say that's a pretty huge moment to say
so as it stands right now in Marvel
Comics um essentially it's it's no
longer you know the lot of Mathew Malloy
who's the most powerful being in
existence it's no longer the Mark II of
death it's no longer any of those guys
instead it is right now basically
Franklin Richards the most powerful
mutant who exists in Marvel Comics is
Franklin Richards most problem powerful
meeting in history right now here's the
important thing to bear in mind is that
mark Wade's writing this from the
perspective of the future right so
basically what's coming what's going on
here is is mark Wade's essentially
saying from you know from the beginning
of the universe all the way until its
eventual end no one will be more
powerful than Franklin Richards there
will not be any mutant out there I'm
more powerful than Franklin Richards
here's a question you have to ask how
many riders are gonna pay attention to
that I doubt very many without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
let's explain and make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later Bruce
[Music]
you
[Music]